[Música]
el segundo test y los tests hay que
hacerlo muy rápido
yo voy a tratar de convencerlos que hay
una creatividad calculable
y yo llegué a eso por en la juventud y
el trabajo de mc escher que quizás lo
conozcan que era un gran dibujante
irlandés y que vemos en su autorretrato
en la esfera en el espejo esférico pero
no vamos a hablar de ella sino que a
partir de su trabajo
este trabajo debe ser
yo conseguí que conseguir un libro de
esther había dejado una pista del
trabajo que es el dibujo que se ve
arriba
que es como la estructura el esqueleto
que lo utilizó para hacer el arte final
de abajo y fue ese esqueleto el que yo
quise reproducir pero sin tener mayor
práctica
me tuve que construir una caja de
cálculo que es esta que se ve aquí que
es mi primera de cajas de cálculo que
todavía a la fecha sigo utilizando pero
que en el momento para mí era muy
novedoso y es pero yo necesitaba un
sistema de referencias de estructural
geométrico muy preciso pero aquí que no
tenía mucha práctica apenas puede hacer
el que se puede ver un poquitico del
dibujo del tubo que yo quería hacer que
no debe ser pero en el próximo aquí si
lo logré y lo que me sucedió aquí fue
que me vi a los 19 años algo así
poseedor de una caja de cálculo que
permitía hacer este tipo de cosas
realmente muy sorprendentes ni nunca
vistas literalmente nunca vistas
que me permitía hacer unas cosas que no
tenían ningún uso práctico pero que era
muy interesante me lancé a hacer
cálculos con esta caja de cálculo y
empecé a sufrir una especie como de
evolución darwiniana tridimensional con
las cajas de cálculos y empezaron a
salir estas figuras
que se fueron complicando
fueron ganando en complejidad y yo mismo
me fui sintiendo progresivamente más
cómodo con la caja de cálculo
que comenzase por ejemplo estas dobles
hélices que es un tema recurrente en el
trabajo en mi trabajo quiero decir
variaciones de las dobles hélices
aquí logra ser mi primera concha
calculada repito yo claro que ha visto
caracoles pero nunca las había calculado
y aquí conseguir la fórmula que ama era
muy precisa y me permitía hacer estas
variaciones desde concha
bueno a mí esto me ha alucinado este
trabajo y yo dedicaba muchísimas horas
para preocupación de mi madre que decía
que porque no hacía un trabajo un poco
más normal o algo así no
y aquí este no sé cómo se ve en la
pantalla este es mi primer intento de
poner a volar las mariposas en doble
hélice cónica que se ve un poquito torpe
en este segundo se ve mucho mejor las
curvas la definición
se ve la caja de cálculo todo esto estos
elementos y todos estos son trabajos
hechos hace muchísimos años en la p
sobre el papel yo tenía muy poca técnica
gráfica
tienen 30 o 40 años por lo menos
[Música]
pero yo
aquí les enseño en mi caja de cálculo la
caja de cálculo que también llamo caja
cartesiana porque tiene en los ejes x y
z cartesiano es una caja que en
perspectiva que permite calcular puntos
en perspectivas con total precisión y yo
digo que usó la caja de cálculo porque
yo no utilizo computadoras yo trabajo en
la mesa de dibujo esta fotografía es de
la semana pasada de manera que no ya
hemos brindado por lo menos 30 años de
lo anterior y la escala de dibujo es la
de las mesas que se ve aquí con la cual
está loma la que obviamente es el
artista
bueno ahora yo voy a pasar al trabajo
profesional que es trabajo actual
comenzando con una fórmula genérica que
yo utilizo para calcular caracoles esta
fórmula genérica es una fórmula que
permite calcular infinitos caracoles con
el solo hecho de modificar las variables
que es la altura del cono o el ancho del
cono y aquí vemos la fórmula en acción
en una caja de cálculos
y esto es un dibujo real fotografía por
fotografía que después se ha hecho una
animación y quiero destacar que la caja
de cálculos es siempre previa al objeto
calculado yo utiliza la caja de cálculo
con un sistema de referencias dentro del
cual crezco el objeto calculado que el
caracol y una vez terminado nunca se me
ocurriría borrar la caja de cálculo
porque me parece que es que son
consustanciales y no y no separable
aquí quiero mostrarles una variación
sobre un tema el tema es la concha plana
y dos ejemplos de concha plana
e
y como usando la misma fórmula se pueden
obtener resultados tan diferentes y las
variaciones sobre un tema es una cosa
que se ve mucho en la naturaleza o en la
música también variaciones sobre un tema
de paganini que sea pero estos son dos
caracoles con una misma fórmula porque
son muy distintos
este primer caracolito es un caracol
hito que es uno en los jardines que es
chiquitito pero yo no sé yo no sé de
biología no sé cómo se llama pero el
segundo sí es muy conocido que es un
canal caracol nautilus y ahora los vemos
aquí terminados se ven metidos en su
apropiada caja de cálculo el día del
nautilus que atrás se ve la curva
originaria que es una espiral
logarítmica tal cosa no nos vamos a
entrar en esos detalles
esta nueva concha yo lo que quiero como
enfatizar es que en realidad las conchas
o los caracoles no son caracoles sino
que son ecuaciones que casualmente se
parecen a los caracoles y a las conchas
esta es una concha áurea hecha con el
rectángulo áureo que es el rectángulo
que se ve a la derecha y las
subdivisiones que tiene adentro son
subdivisiones áureas hechas con la
fórmula original de caracol que vimos al
principio y después vemos el caracol a
medio hacer en su caja de cálculos y eso
en realidad no es un caracol es una
ecuación graficadas por decirlo una
manera sin embargo cuando yo termino de
hacer ese cálculo cualquier persona sin
ningún tipo de entrenamiento no le cabe
duda de que son un caracol
aunque no sepa el nombre científico y
bueno mucho menos con estos colores pero
pero pero pero que un caracol sin lugar
a dudas y no es un caracol sino que es
un cálculo del que éste es una sección
se ve el número áureo 1 618 en el
acotamiento y se venda los cortes de los
diámetros etcétera y aquí yo estoy con
un compás áureo
verificando que es dos diámetros
sucesivos tienen una relación áurea
entonces aprovecho para hacer un pequeño
inciso para hablar un poquitico de la
espiral de fibonacci y el número áureo
toda espiral de fibonacci que es esa que
vemos ahí está inscrita en su
correspondiente rectángulo áureo lo que
quiere decir que son equivalentes y yo
en mi geometría
hablo muchas veces de fibonacci o de
áureo indistintamente porque porque son
equivalentes el hecho de que ésta quepa
en el rectángulo abrió
y matemáticamente le da el mismo número
16 18
y el número áureo y la espiral de
fibonacci se encuentran en la naturaleza
en los ritmos de los crecimientos de la
de las plantas y en muchos fenómenos
pero pero bueno ese no es el tema de
este té sino lo mi dibujo
estos son dibujos un poco como de
virtuosismo que yo hago para mí para mis
redes estos son cuatro espirales bonacci
que están en sus respectivas del
rectángulo saurios
que son que si las hicieran en
computadora probablemente sería muy
fácil pero hechos a mano sin tinta no te
puedes ni equivocar por eso es que digo
que son un poco virtuosístico hay que
tener por lo menos mucha práctica
este es las mismas espirales anteriores
pero con su simetría o sea que son ocho
espirales son cuatro y cuatro que son
las mismas reflejadas a un eje de
simetría que pasa por el medio pero no
creo que se distinga que aquí en los
dibujos
estas son tres espirales de fibonacci
repartidas equidistantes en un círculo y
aquí les agregue unas joyas para
convertirlas vamos a decir que en otra
cosa
este es un uso práctico de el número
áureo o esperará en fibonacci se ve en
las paredes del dibujo de la espiral de
fútbol así que es para el cálculo de
sólidos platónicos que de otra manera
son muy difíciles de calcular
tridimensionalmente y cuando yo descubrí
esta fórmula que no la descubrí yo
pero pero si la la utilice porque no
decía muy bien como es usado en internet
no se van a conseguir
pude calcular finalmente el dow decae
drone que es el penúltimo sólido de los
cinco sólidos platónicos y el último es
el ico cedro que se calcula casi solo es
muy fácil bueno hay que tener un poquito
de práctica
[Música]
esta promedia la calcula también con el
número áureo pero yo insisto yo no hago
la problema la bromelia y después pinto
todas las rayas como para tirarme la
pintaba lo ha sido y yo hago las rayas y
después después cálculo hoja por hoja la
bromelia quizás con esto lo que quiero
decir que es un sistema bastante
solvente y que los manejo solventemente
esto para terminar el inciso son dos
diseños en retícula hexagonal
este es un
[Música]
arabescos sin terminar para que se vea
un poco los intríngulis del cálculo
geométrico y este otro que es bien
interesante que es un óculo gótico que
esté escrito en una retícula hexagonal
que se llama la flor de la vida y que lo
conoce la gente que hace geometría
sagrada que yo no hago geometría sagrada
yo hago eso metría
pero cuando estuve haciendo este en la
medida que lo ya desentrañando yo me
estaba copiando una foto pero que no
decía cómo se hacía cuando yo lo estaba
geometrizando fue saliendo paralelamente
en la flor de la vida de esta que más
agrada que se yo y me asombro muchísimo
que el diseño este gótico lo hicieron
800 años con la flor de la vida y bueno
por eso lo que hice como traer porque me
pareció y además es muy bonito el diseño
pero bueno ahora está volviendo otra vez
a mi trabajo profesional tridimensional
estos son mis secuencias de vuelo que
por razones obvias se llama así
ellos son una combinación de simplicidad
y complejidad al mismo tiempo porque yo
describo unos buenos que son
[Música]
muy casual desde en este caso de cinco
mariposas y las sombras que arrojan el
piso pero si uno se fija en la
estructura geométrica que se necesita
para sustentarlos en el espacio es una
dualidad de simplicidad de complejidad
que se nota todavía más en este dibujo
de la de la monarca volando sobre un
espejo de agua que yo primero hice todas
las rayas y después pinte las mariposas
apoyándome las rayas porque es por eso
digo que esto es una con una combinación
de simple con complejo
y este próximo dibujo que no voy a
pretender que es sencillo porque de
entrada se ve bastante complicado
lo que quiero es estas son una secuencia
que se refleja contra un espejo al fondo
y está todo calculado y lo que quiero es
mostrar el cálculo
no tan rápido para
bueno y aquí se termina la era más
espaciada pero bueno
y ahora quiero volver a hacer una
comparación de variaciones sobre un tema
como hicimos con los caracoles de esta
doble espiral cónica metida en su caja
de cálculo las cajas de cálculos son
casi idénticas las fórmulas idénticas
las secuencias idénticas pero los
resultados apartando el color que es lo
más evidente son diferentes las
proporciones son distintas
puede ver que esta es más ancha la otra
es más esbelta en fin que uno puede
lograr en un contexto muy similar
variaciones con un carácter muy
diferente e incluso gustarle más una que
a otra que a mí me gusta más esta azul y
lo que quiero destacar aquí es que
dentro de un contexto tan estricto en
este caso geométricamente estricto
con el manejo apropiado
cabal de la de las variables y de los
elementos constitutivos uno puede ser
realmente
creativo que uno pensaría que es todo lo
contrario porque uno pensaría que la
creatividad solamente hija de la
libertad total o cosas por el estilo
porque uno puede ser creativa en estos
esquemas tan estrictos
y ahora en esta caja de cálculo les voy
a crecer una doble hélice como la que
vimos antes partiendo desde la cota 0 y
apoyándome en la caja de cálculo para
crecer para tener las referencias
geométricas creció más rápido lo que
debería y después el agregar color se
individualizan las mariposas
y se tiene la obra terminada
yo con estos trabajos quiero como
enfatizar que si bien es cierto que la
creatividad es por definición un
ejercicio de la libertad
existe no obstante otro tipo de
creatividad que está
y da a reglas estrictas y que no por eso
es menos libre que una creatividad sin
normas y sin pautas que es el
estereotipo que se tiene de la libertad
creativa y no es verdad existen existen
creatividad es que están que obedecen a
reglas estrictas
y aquí vemos esta secuencia de la
mariposa amorfo volando sobre un espejo
de agua
y con ella me despido muchas gracias
[Aplausos]